hi I'm Tiffani Thiessen and today I'm
making my mom's famous cream cheese pie
I love this cream cheese pie one because
it has cheese in it and I'm a cheese
lover and two because it was something
that my mom always made and it was
something that brought memories every
time I would have a bite I remember
literally growing up having this cream
cheese pie at every special occasion and
holiday I don't remember exactly the
first time I made this pie and it was
quite a long time ago and I do remember
being very nervous about it because it's
a staple in our family and I wanted to
make sure I did it right what's unique
about this recipe is that most people
think it's a cheesecake but it's
actually not it's more of a cream cheese
pie so it has a little more of the
texture of an actual pie this cream
cheese pie is something that when I make
it for somebody who hasn't had it before
they want to know why I haven't had it
before everybody who makes it everybody
who has it it's something that gets
requested over and over and over again
and I think it's gonna be the same for
you guys we usually make the cream
cheese pie for special occasions and
mostly during the holidays but my
daughter does request it on her birthday
as well my daughter and I cook a lot
together she is now seven and a half
years old so she's getting pretty good
at it she actually has her own set of
knives kid knives of course but she's
getting really great at it she likes to
be alongside me and we are definitely
making memories in the kitchen that says
special time right now I started cooking
as a young little girl kind of pairing
my head through the corner watching the
other ladies and my family cooking
together and I wanted to be with them I
think for me being in the kitchen and
cooking it
just another expression of being
artistic I also love trying new things
and being able to be creative and trying
new ingredients and trying new
techniques is something that I love to
do and I love also what food does I love
that food brings people together it's a
communal type thing and whether it's
your family your friends or whatever I
really love what she does
oh yes
you